how do you follow up a masterpiece if
Nintendo has taught us anything it's to
get weird with it
ditching the familiarity of Hyrule
Princess Zelda and Ganon
link washes up on the mysterious shores
of ko Hollen Island he befriends a Chain
Chomp stomps goombahs and meets a quirky
cast of characters 26 years later Link's
Awakening is still considered one of
these strangest Zelda games ever made
and that's no coincidence
director Takashi Tezuka and his team had
an unusual influenced David Lynch's Twin
Peaks but how did two Zuka get from a
show about a small-town murder
investigation to Link's Awakening it
started when he and programmer Kazuaki
Morita began messing around with a Game
Boy dev kit after work they wanted to
see if they could port the SNES hit a
Link to the Past to the Game Boy as this
after-hours project took shape Tezuka
formally pitched a handheld Zelda game
to Nintendo and was given the greenlight
however as development progressed the
team decided to make a brand new zelda
adventure rather than just a port with
this new directive - Zuko brought on Ken
skate inaba and Yoshi Akiko Izumi to
write the script
both devs worked on a link to the past
however Kazumi who had a background in
filmmaking wrote the instruction manual
he believed that video games could
convey drama and storytelling in a
unique way but up until this point most
Nintendo games were made with gameplay
and mind sure they had an overarching
goal and a loose narrative like save the
princess or save the other princess but
ko Izumi wanted to dig deeper ko assume
his ideas align almost perfectly with
what to Zuka had in mind given the
limitations of the Game Boy to Zuko
wanted to give links awakenings Island a
small-town vibe with distinct
characteristics
he gave koa Sumi and Tanabe permission
to cut some of the series most familiar
aspects with that mind ko Azumi and
Tanabe created a quirky cast of
characters although dialogue is sparse
these characters and the conversations
you have with them adds a lot of flavor
to the island in their own ways these
characters served a greater narrative
rather than just gameplay it's pretty
hard to forget some of the strange
people you meet on this adventure like
the shy grandpa or IRRI and the ghost
who is trying to find his way back home
but how does all this relate with twin
peaks'
well you'd be hard-pressed
find any direct references to Twin Peaks
but there are a lot of parallels in a
roundtable conversation with former
nintendo president Satoru Iwata Zelda
series producer Eiji Aonuma ant azúcar
Tezuka directly calls out Twin Peaks and
says I was talking about fashioning
Link's Awakening with a feel that
somewhat like Twin Peaks the drama was
all about a small number of characters
in a small town you can see these
similarities right at the beginning like
Dale Cooper Twin Peaks protagonist link
is a city boy who now finds himself in a
small town at the time Link's Awakening
was the first in the series to take
place outside of Hyrule this means that
for the first time link in the player
were both exploring an unfamiliar world
together and trying to make sense of it
Dale Cooper is faced with a similar
challenge when he arrives in Twin Peaks
if I haven't made it obvious yet both
Twin Peaks and Link's Awakening have
their fair share of quirky characters
Link's Awakening has mr. right who
spends his days writing letters that
never get a response and Twin Peaks has
log lady a woman who carries around a
log and claims to have a psychic
connection to it one day my log will
have something to say about this dreams
also play a huge role in both of them
there are a number of characters and
Link's Awakening that referenced their
dreams and in Twin Peaks Dale Cooper
uses his dreams to help further his
investigation however to Zuka and his
team's fascination with Twin Peaks
shouldn't come as a surprise believe it
or not despite only being available on
one network Twin Peaks took off in Japan
and Link's Awakening certainly isn't the
only Japanese Twin Peaks inspired game
that's right I'm looking at you Deadly
Premonition but what did this odd take
on the Zelda series mean for the
franchise
well for one Link's Awakening is greater
emphasis on story and weird characters
is something that is stuck with the
series ever since the only other game in
the franchise to rival Link's Awakening
on the weirdness scale is Majora's Mask
and wouldn't you know it Majora's Mask
is directed by none other than Kazumi
Zelda games don't get weird often but
when they do it's a refreshingly
different and memorable take on the
beloved franchise and if you ask me we
have Twin Peaks to thank for that
[Music]